wir können ja nicht davon ausgehen zu
sagen wir holen uns jetzt Fachkräfte aus
Rumänien aus Bulgarien was passiert denn
eigentlich in diesen Ländern weil wenn
diese dort fehlen haben wir ja schon
gemacht das haben wir alles längst
abgegrast und und da kommt auch kein
neuer Wohlstand her ja jetzt Hool ich
aber den Rasen mehr raus ich möchte
jetzt grasen also von daher der Punkt
ist dann wir schaffen dann im Prinzip in
diesen Ländern noch größere Probleme und
die Abwanderung zu uns weil die
Perspektivlosigkeit in diesen Ländern
noch viel größer ist die ist noch größer
wenn dort Ärzte weggehen wenn dort
Kindergärten wegen Pflegekräfte wegen
fehlen die auch dort auch dort brauchen
die Menschen und die altere Bevölkerung
genau diese Menschen also wir schaffen
dann in diesen neuen Ländern Probleme
für mich ist das moderner Kolonialismus
das muss ich wirklich
kritisieren ja in der Form dass wir
anderen Ländern Diesel die Fachkräfte
abwerben die wir eigentlich selber die
sie selber in diesen Ländern bräuchten
es also es ist mit nichten so dass wir
den Leuten nur ihre Arbeitskräfte und
Fachkräfte wegnehmen Serbien es gibt's
andere Probleme und da gehen viele hier